so
morbius is an interesting movie and it's
something i've been wanting to discuss
for a long time i remember when the film
first hit theaters i was pretty lukewarm
on the whole affair to say the least i
was too busy losing my mind at how good
spy family was and here comes sony being
like hey guys our vampire movie is
pretty cool
you know michael morbius right buddy if
i wanted vampires named michael i'd play
melty blood but then i started to see a
lot of buzz about morbius online
everyone was really talking this up as
one of the greats saying that it wasn't
your average superhero romp so i decided
you know what okay i'll bite and so i
bought the movie on the google play
store since you know i needed to morph
in full 4k and watched it with a few
close friends and i have to say i was
shocked this was not the drab generic
focus tested adaptation of a cape flick
that i thought it was going to be if
anything after i was done with the
film's 1 hour and 44 minute run time
i was a changed man
this film embodies everything that's
great not only about superhero movies
but frankly
film and art as a whole
it's something that i think more people
should be talking about
i'm red muffler man and today fellow
morph heads we'll be tackling just that
morbius the living vampire he's been a
mainstay in marvel comics for decades
having made his first appearance in
spider-man 101 in 1971. since then he's
made multiple on and off appearances and
while initially being portrayed as a
villain quickly found a place in the
pantheon of marvel as a relatable
anti-hero
he was simply a sick man who wanted
nothing more than a cure to the rare
disease that nailed him and through his
desperation found a cure that was
anything but
jared leto takes the pained character of
dr michael morbius and plays it to an
absolute master class level he portrays
the character with a solemn anguish a
man pushing away his colleagues and
close friends and going to extreme
lengths to cling to even the smallest
fragment of hope he can muster hope is
generally a strong theme found in the
film and no character represents the
message of hope better than michael
morbius's close friend milo played by
the english heartthrob matt smith in one
of michael's darkest hours during his
adolescence as he had given up and was
willing to let the nihilism of his
situation take hold
there was milo someone just like him
with the same rare blood disease it's
honestly touching seeing the two boys
share a moment to reassure themselves
that while the world may be a dark
unforgiving place
at least when they were together there's
hope but as time passes and michael
makes breakthrough after breakthrough he
still can't find the one solution to the
problem that is the time limit on his
life and slowly the walls come closing
in closer and closer and closer
eventually the same hope that pushed him
to keep going in the first place becomes
twisted and distorted
and forces the young man into a dark
place he had no intention of ever going
having taken a horde of vampire bats
from costa rica michael takes one final
gambit to take on his disease the morb
serum short for miraculous obfuscation
replacement blood it would allow him to
take all of the recessive disease-ridden
cells in his body and replaced them with
the dominant red blood cells found
within the body of the vampire bats
known for their resilience against
various diseases like rabies with one
final chance at obtaining a life free of
the ever looming presence of death dr
michael morbius injects himself with the
serum whilst on board a freight ship and
at first everything appears to be a
browsing success
michael is able to walk on his own
properly his strength speed and senses
are downright superhuman
he's the best he's felt in his entire
life
but then something strange begins
happening he begins to see
red and he is overcome with insatiable
bloodlust dr michael morbius at this
moment has lost his humanity breaking
free from his restraints morbis attacks
and kills everyone aboard the ship sans
his partner dr martin boncroft draining
them of all of their blood
this scene is a violent bloody spectacle
the entirety of the scene is veiled in a
pitch black whereas previous scenes were
bright and vibrant to show some element
of hope in this ordeal
now there's only the darkness of despair
leaving even the viewer in both the
literal and figurative dark as they must
quickly attempt to parse the acts of
vampire based carnage and violence that
morbius is morbing on his prey and like
a fever dream as quickly as the outburst
of bloody murder violence begins
so too does it end dr michael morbius
now coming to the realization that
within him lies a dormant beast that he
has no hope of reigning in as he deals
with the impending duality of morbius
the man and morbius the monster this
theme of duality and the intertwined
themes of hope and despair are further
intertwined in the narrative of morbius
as the movie progresses they go only
further into the twisting yin and yang
that is the tale of the tragic doctor as
we are reintroduced to milo
milo after having been denied the cure
for michael who sees his new abilities
as a curse steals the vile of the morb
serum for himself milo unlike michael
morbius doesn't see the vampiric urges
as a curse
he sees them as a ticket to freedom
to live the life he feels he had been
robbed of by the powers on high matt
smith does an incredible job of
portraying the unhinged freedom of milo
with this
incredibly playful spirit
it's funny how they got jared leto to
play the joker when matt smith was
literally right there like come on give
matt smith the damage tattoo and let him
go warner brothers well let him at it
once your merger with discovery stop
setting everything on fire but i digress
by this point of the movie i was
entertained but it wasn't exactly
anything
new to me
i thought at this point maybe the 16 on
rotten tomatoes was right and
maybe people were just pulling my leg on
this
then
something changed something i never
would have expected in a movie like
morbius the scene begins with morbius's
escape from law enforcement having just
discovered milo's theft of the morb
serum going to confront his old friend
milo flaunting his new powers refuses to
give up his new lease on life as he
effortlessly defeats michael morbius at
this point milo has fully embraced his
vampiric abilities while michael fights
desperately to hold on to what little
humanity he has left
then as milo is about to strike a
finishing blow
there is
a quiet a stillness one could only
perceive when they were moving around
at the speed of sound in that brief
moment milo is blasted away by a surge
of energy
morbius on his knees looks up at the
outstretched hand of his savior and sees
none other
than sonic the hedgehog
at this point my friends and i began
losing our sh we knew this movie had
become a meme but we thought it was from
a place of irony but we had no idea that
we were about to experience peak cinema
from here morbius using the power of one
of the chaos emeralds gains the power of
flight and together he and sonic managed
to escape milo sonic then takes morbius
to his underground base and the two
formally introduce themselves sonic
explains that he'd been transported to
this dimension alongside his friend
knuckles by the insidious dr robotnik at
that moment morbius remembers that
robotnik was one of his research mates
from his university days someone whom he
had confided much of his research it
turns out milo had not stolen the morph
serum from him but the robotnik had
reverse engineered the serum boosting
its effects using the power of the chaos
emeralds having a common enemy morbius
and sonic join forces in order to stop
both milo and dr robotnik and to get
sonic and knuckles back safely to their
world however as time progresses sonic
and morbius can't track down milo or
robotnik the two spend days tracking
their movements finding only bodies in
their wake
meanwhile morbis's vampiric instincts
only grow more insatiable by the day
as the artificial blood used to sustain
him grows less effective by the hour
then during their investigation sonic
catches a glimpse of knuckles and gives
chase and as this happens morbius
unaware of sonic's actions receives a
mysterious phone call hello dr michael
morbius
doctor
ivan robotnik
or is it eggman these days
robotnik calls taunting the young
anti-hero how he's kidnapped not only
sonic
but his beloved martine and should he
wish to see them in one piece that he
must hand over the final chaos emerald
by midnight tonight more beast makes a
mad dash to downtown new york where he
is greeted by both milo
and robotnik sonic and martine both
restrained morbius begrudgingly hands
over the final chaos emerald to ensure
their safety robotnik and milo however
had other plans with the seven emeralds
in hand milo fatally wounds both martine
and sonic throwing their bodies to
morbius's feet in a blind rage morbius
attacks milo but now as he has received
the power of the chaos emeralds super
milo easily disposes of morbius and the
powerless chaos emeralds leaving with
robotnik to wreak havoc on an
unsuspecting world morbius has been
defeated
with his only allies dying mere inches
from his reach martine reaches out to
him
begging him to drink her blood
to fully embrace the beast within
to do what he must to stop milo with
tears in his eyes he drinks her blood
and as he screams in despair the
powerless emeralds begin to react milo
had only taken the negative power of the
emeralds but not the positive and as the
emeralds gather around morbius and sonic
the pure morb energy from michael's body
begins to flow all around
gifting sonic the same vampiric
abilities as he is reborn
as supersonic morbius
the two confront milo and robotnik with
their newfound strength in which
robotnik reveals his final trump card
knuckles who had been turned by the
serum and who has fully embraced the red
but filled with the burning justice to
take down robotnik super milo and
knuckles
morbius and sonic unleash their true
power and charge it's morbid time
the battle is long and hard fought but
eventually sonic and morbius are the
victors with milo having been stripped
of his abilities using the positive
energy of the emeralds and leaving him
to die of his illness while knuckles
breaks robotnik's brainwashing
and together he and sonic take down
their longtime adversary has brothers in
arms with the battle over sonic and
knuckles use the power of the emeralds
to return to their original forms
purging themselves of the essence of
morb morbius however when given the
chance to return to being human refuses
them that he has become the avatar of
the morb and must learn to control its
wrath from within now at this point i
didn't think this film could get any
better honestly but then we hit the
post-credits scene which apparently
this scene wasn't in the theatrical cut
so maybe that could have led to the
movie's negative reception upon release
since
it very cleanly
ties the narrative together we cut to
the scene morbius and sonic are alone on
the outskirts of new york having been
called by a mysterious unnamed man they
speak to one another briefly wondering
what's going on when they hear a voice
[Music]
what's up dak morby's turns
and is greeted by bugs bunny into his
sides are both lebron james and son goku
bugs then explains that the multiverse
has been torn asunder which has led to
the return of the multiversal monstars
and in order to defeat them bugs and
lebron have been gathering the
universe's strongest warriors which has
led them directly to dr michael morbius
god i i'm so
excited for what we're gonna get in
morbius too cause this is just the tip
of the iceberg man like i don't think
they can do any better than this i don't
think any other movie can do better than
this at this point like i'm done this is
peak cinema you can't do any better than
this i'm so confused why people are
hating on this movie i swear to god we
we had to have seen two different movies
like what is happening but that's enough
out of me if you like what we do like
subscribe and drop a comment
it really helps us out and if you like
me you can find me on twitch twitter and
youtube
at redmufflerman
and
yeah
i'm all morphed out so
take it easy everybody